其他人：哦这 他妈剪衣服
Others: Oh, damn, cutting clothes.
Jake: 哎你好你好你好
Jake: Hey, hello, hello, hello.
Shure: hello
Shure: Hello.
Jake: 你好你好
Jake: Hi, hi.
Jake: 你好你好你好
Jake: Hello, hello, hello.
Jake: 眼镜呢
Jake: Where are the glasses?
Shure: 眼镜在我包包里
Shure: The glasses are in my bag.
Jake: 导出来了吗
Jake: Did you export them?
Jake: 行那你给我导一下
Jake: Alright, export them for me.
Shure: 突然发现那什么
Shure: Suddenly realized that...
Jake: 卡拉OK OK吗
Jake: Karaoke, is it okay?
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake: 答辩OK
Jake: The defense is okay.
Shure: 还OK
Shure: It's okay.
Jake: 谢谢
Jake: Thanks.
Shure:  安迪人特好
Shure: Andy is really nice.
Shure: 他非常有耐心
Shure: He's very patient.
Shure: 虽然我夹的是一口答辩
Shure: Although I messed up the defense.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
其他人： 我跟你说个逆天了啊
Others: Let me tell you something unbelievable.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
其他人：那天晚上学姐开了20分钟车啊
Others: That night, the senior drove for 20 minutes.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
其他人：然后扣了6分
Others: And got 6 points deducted.
Jake: 卧槽为什么
Jake: What the hell, why?
其他人： 因为闯红灯
Others: Because of running a red light.
Jake: 闯红灯
Jake: Running a red light.
Jake: 学姐开车闯红灯
Jake: The senior ran a red light.
其他人：他那天晚上没看见
Others: They didn't see it that night.
Jake: 哦那也不是他的问题
Jake: Oh, then it's not their fault.
Jake: 路的问题
Jake: The road issue.
其他人：北京的问题
Others: The Beijing issue.
Jake: 北京的问题
Jake: The Beijing issue.
其他人： 我刚才在路上
Others: I was just on the road.
其他人：一路学法减分
Others: Learned the traffic laws all the way to reduce points.
其他人：学完法减完分
Others: Finished learning and reduced the points.
其他人：减了一分
Others: Reduced one point.
Jake: 为什么
Jake: Why?
其他人：就让我看交通教育视频考试减了一份
Others: They made me watch a traffic education video and took a test to reduce one point.
Jake: 哦哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh, oh.
Jake: 现在考5分了是吧
Jake: Now you score 5 points, right?
Lucia: 没什么啊
Lucia: It's nothing.
Shure: 没醒是吗
Shure: Not awake, huh?
Lucia: 醒了醒了
Lucia: Awake, awake.
Jake: 打工呢好像
Jake: Seems like working.
Lucia: 我们我们上午已经已经录了一段了
Lucia: We've already recorded a segment this morning.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Tasha: 结束一轮
Tasha: Finished a round.
Tasha: 结束一轮活动
Tasha: Finished a round of activities.
Jake: 哦对然后现在已经开始主播模式了
Jake: Oh right, and now we're in streaming mode.
Jake: 就是眼镜已经不当眼镜用了就
Jake: So the glasses aren't just for glasses anymore.
其他人：要导数据吗
Others: Need to import data?
Jake: 要要要这个这个
Jake: Yes, yes, this one, this one.
Jake: 很重要这个很重要
Jake: Very important, this is very important.
Jake: 好好好行
Jake: Okay, okay, fine.
Jake: 眼镜先给我
Jake: Give me the glasses first.
Jake: 我我先倒一个
Jake: Let me transfer one first.
Shure:  人类恋爱日常素材
Shure: Human love daily materials.
Jake: 我靠
Jake: Oh my god.
Jake: 有点牛逼
Jake: Kind of awesome.
其他人：我靠这床怎么睡的
Others: Oh my god, how do you sleep on this bed?
Jake: 可以
Jake: It's okay.
Jake: 这这这个都可以
Jake: This, this, this is all good.
Jake: 亲啊
Jake: Dear.
其他人：你晚上怎么睡
Others: How do you sleep at night?
Jake: 我是在中间哦
Jake: I'm in the middle.
Jake: 我要把这个挪开
Jake: I need to move this.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake: 也可以我觉得对
Jake: It works, I think, yeah.
其他人：确实
Others: Indeed.
其他人：要不然再学学
Other: How about you learn it again?
其他人：你学一遍给你补几分
Other: If you learn it once, we can give you some extra points.
其他人：就补一分
Other: Just one point though.
其他人：那还是别学了
Other: Then forget it, no need to learn it.
Jake: 那学6遍不就好了吗是吗
Jake: How about learning it 6 times then, right?
其他人：你看它这个颜色我个人感觉他是能扣个能
Other: Look at its color, personally, I think it could be deducted.
Shure: 不是你减分数就是
Shure: Are you saying you're reducing points?
其他人：对啊你看它这个
Other: Yeah, look at this.
Jake: 来来看看一下
Jake: Come on, take a look.
Jake: 我迭代出来的
Jake: This is what I iterated.
Jake: 拍完带
Jake: Finished and ready to go.
其他人：OK啊
其他人：是怎么昨天晚上就巧妙了
Other: How did it turn out so clever last night?
Jake: 巧妙啊巧妙
Jake: Clever, really clever.
Jake: 巧妙是用的超能力
Jake: The cleverness came from using superpowers.
其他人：是吗
Other: Really?
Jake: 花了2,000块钱
Jake: Spent 2,000 bucks.
其他人：为什么
Other: Why?
Jake: 买了15张SD卡
Jake: Bought 15 SD cards.
其他人：你早说呀
Other: You should have told us earlier.
其他人：我把我那SD带来了
Other: I brought my SD card too.
Jake: 那16张是吧
Jake: So, that's 16 then?
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 我正在想
Lucia: I'm just thinking.
Lucia: 哈哈我主要是懒得卸妆
Lucia: Haha, I mainly don't want to remove my makeup.
Jake: 我靠这个这东西只能靠超能力
Jake: Man, this thing only works with superpowers.
Jake: 他妈的
Jake: Damn it.
Jake: 这个传数据比我想象的慢多了
Jake: Transferring data is way slower than I thought.
其他人：嗯就算用SD应该也到不了七八百吧
Other: Even with an SD card, it probably won't reach 700-800.
Shure: 这个视频能导出给我一份吗
Shure: Can you export this video for me?
Jake: 可以可以
Jake: Sure, sure.
Jake: 之之后都可以给你们
Jake: I can give it to you all later.
Jake: 然后但是要处理一下
Jake: But we need to process it.
Jake: 因为这个文件格式不太对
Jake: Because the file format isn't quite right.
Shure: 只要我昨天晚上那一
Shure: I only need the one from last night.
Jake: 你别的不要也行
Jake: You don't need the others, right?
其他人：我懂了我给你学6次一共能减6分
Other: Got it, I'll learn it 6 times to reduce 6 points.
Jake: 好
Jake: Good.
Shure: 以后是我的亡妻回忆录的一部分
Shure: It'll be part of my memoir for my late wife.
Jake: 哈哈我草
Jake: Haha, damn.
Jake: 录下来了我草
Jake: It's recorded, damn.
Jake: 就是这边硬盘每人有一个
Jake: Everyone has a hard drive here.
Jake: 然后插线板可能还得要一个
Jake: And we'll probably need another power strip.
Jake: 因为楼上和楼下的GoPro
Jake: Because the GoPros upstairs and downstairs...
Jake: 还得专门有一台存呢
Jake: They each need a dedicated storage.
Jake: 现在都在
Jake: Everything's on...
Jake: 现在都在SD卡里面
Jake: Everything's on the SD cards.
Jake: 根本导不出来
Jake: Can't export anything.
Jake: 太他妈慢了
Jake: It's so damn slow.
Jake: 15台太慢了
Jake: 15 devices are too slow.
Jake: 我靠妈的
Jake: Damn it.
其他人：导一条得多久
Others: How long does it take to export one?
Jake: 呃 1 pens
Jake: Uh, 1 pens.
Jake: 对大概真的就是他说是3个小时
Jake: Yeah, he says it takes about 3 hours.
Jake: 我估计一个小时
Jake: I estimate an hour.
Jake: 一个小时一台
Jake: An hour per device.
Jake: 然后我现在就是有这么两
Jake: And now I have two...
Jake: 就是相当于两波有SD卡
Jake: Basically two batches of SD cards.
Jake: 所以说就是换一波下来
Jake: So when one batch is done...
Jake: 然后开始疯狂导
Jake: We start exporting like crazy.
Jake: 就是在这边就疯狂导
Jake: Just exporting like crazy here.
Jake: 对就有轮换的时间
Jake: Yeah, we have rotation time.
Jake: 不然根本他妈的一个小时导不出来
Jake: Otherwise, damn, we can't export in an hour.
Jake: 焦头烂额
Jake: It's driving me nuts.
Jake: 卧槽呵呵呵呵
Jake: Damn, haha.
其他人：正好我今天牙好了
Others: Just right, my tooth is better today.
Jake: 牙好了你牙怎么就好了呢
Jake: Your tooth is better? How did it get better?
其他人： 就是得出一天血
Others: It just bled for a day.
其他人：出两天血
Others: Bled for two days.
Jake: 好这边硬盘每次开一下
Jake: Okay, open the hard drive every time.
其他人：太可怕了
Others: That's terrifying.
其他人：嗯就是人类
Others: Yeah, it's just human...
其他人：人类神奇的东西
Others: Humans are amazing.
其他人：这是一晚上的产物
Others: This is a night's result.
Jake: 这什么呀
Jake: What is this?
其他人： 这就是血包
Others: This is a blood clot.
Jake: 血包
Jake: Blood clot?
Jake: 血包是从哪
Jake: Where did the blood clot come from?
其他人：凝固的血
Others: Coagulated blood.
Jake: 血就是在牙上这边嗯
Jake: The blood is from the tooth here, hmm.
Lucia: 我还没到呢
Lucia: I'm not there yet.
Shure: 这是啥呀这是室外的
Shure: What's this? This is outdoors.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Lucia: 其实还挺好吃的
Lucia: Actually, it's pretty tasty.
Tasha: 真的真的
Tasha: Really, really.
Tasha: 杨老师吃的
Tasha: Jake is eating it.
Tasha: 你尝他吃的
Tasha: You should try what he's eating.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈我靠
Jake: Hahaha, oh my god.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 这还有这还有别的
Lucia: There's more, there's more.
Tasha: 这还有这还有别的你为什么不尝啊
Tasha: There's more, there's more, why don't you try it?
Lucia: 真挺好吃的
Lucia: It's really tasty.
Lucia: 这真挺好吃
Lucia: It's really good.
Lucia: 我早上吃了好多块
Lucia: I had a lot this morning.
Tasha: 真的吗
Tasha: Really?
Tasha:  那就好哈哈
Tasha: That's good, haha.
Lucia: 那个锅确实可能导热有点快
Lucia: That pot might heat up a bit fast.
Lucia: 就外面稍微有点焦
Lucia: So the outside got a bit burnt.
Lucia: 对焦的地方就会稍微有一点点苦
Lucia: The burnt part is a bit bitter.
Lucia: 但是本身就是那些没有被烧焦的地方
Lucia: But the parts that aren't burnt are really delicious.
Lucia: 真的很好吃
Lucia: It's really good.
Tasha: 好谢谢你
Tasha: Great, thank you.
Tasha: 明天还做给你吃
Tasha: I'll make it for you again tomorrow.
Lucia: 不用谢真的挺好吃的
Lucia: No need to thank me, it's really good.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈好好好
Jake: Hahaha, alright, alright.
Lucia: 发自内心的
Lucia: From the bottom of my heart.
Tasha: 觉得蘸糖好吃吗
Tasha: Do you think it's better with sugar?
Lucia: 我觉得蘸不蘸糖都还不错
Lucia: I think it's good with or without sugar.
Lucia: 作为一个北方人
Lucia: As a northerner,
Jake: 他抽烟去了
Jake: He went for a smoke.
Lucia: 就蘸不蘸糖都没所谓了
Lucia: It's fine with or without sugar.
其他人：没抽烟
Others: No smoking.
Jake: 嗯不准抽了上来吧
Jake: Hmm, no smoking, come on up.
Jake: 抽烟被学姐骂是吧
Jake: Got scolded by the senior for smoking?
其他人： 没有吧啊
Others: I don't think so.
Jake: 学姐不骂你
Jake: The senior won't scold you.
其他人：这就是我抽烟啊啊
Others: That's why I'm smoking.
Jake: 就是单纯的晕车
Jake: It's just motion sickness.
其他人：他后来开完
Others: He drove later.
其他人：他后来回去开完车就原谅了我
Others: He drove later and forgave me.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
其他人： 不是我的问题
Others: It's not my problem.
其他人： 是车的问题
Others: It's the car's problem.
Jake: 好吧好吧
Jake: Alright, alright.
Jake: 呃这边就是这个
Jake: Uh, over here, it's like this.
Jake: 就是超能力超出来的
Jake: It's like superpowers brought it out.
Jake: 嗯 256 g的卡
Jake: Hmm, a 256 GB card.
Jake: 然后每一个go Pro
Jake: And each GoPro...
Jake: 现在里边已经基本上都满了
Jake: They're pretty much all full now.
Jake: 256 g 250
Jake: 256 GB, 250...
Jake: 什么东西
Jake: What?
Jake: 就是1百二十八g然后128G
Jake: So 128 GB, then another 128 GB.
Jake: 我们要把里边的卡都换掉
Jake: We need to swap out all the cards.
Jake: 然后换的话就是每一个要有一个编号
Jake: And when we swap them, each one needs a number.
Jake: 因为回去我们要倒
Jake: Because we need to copy them later.
Jake: 就是要写一下
Jake: We need to note them down.
Jake: 我们分一下
Jake: Let's sort them out.
Jake: 好吧
Jake: Alright.
其他人：这个4-17
Others: This is 4-17.
其他人： 这是什么
Others: What's this?
Jake: 今天
Jake: Today.
Jake: 哦今天的数据
Jake: Oh, today's data.
Jake: 对 9号go Pro 9是这边
Jake: Yeah, GoPro 9 is over here.
Jake: 这边看下面
Jake: Look down here.
Jake: 九十1112131415
Jake: Nine, ten, eleven, twelve, thirteen, fourteen, fifteen.
其他人：楼下那个现在改成1号
Others: The one downstairs is now number 1.
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Jake: 呃
Jake: Uh.
Jake: 哎
Jake: Hey.
Jake: 给给你一个10
Jake: Here, take a 10.
Jake: 就是这个
Jake: This one.
Jake: 每次我们倒完之后就把它撕掉
Jake: Every time we finish copying, we just remove it.
Jake: 呃也不是撕掉吧
Jake: Uh, not remove it.
Jake: 就是再贴一个上
Jake: Just stick another one on.
Jake: 去就是就就再贴一个上去
Jake: Yeah, just stick another one on.
Jake: 就是使或者把这个化掉
Jake: Or cross this one out.
Jake: 就是就意思是4月17号倒完了
Jake: It means we finished copying on April 17th.
Jake: 然后他是一个就
Jake: And then a new card should come in.
Jake: 倒完之后应该会有一个新卡进来
Jake: It's just a rotation.
Jake: 就是轮换的
Jake: It's a rotation.
Jake: 然后可能就是14月10八
Jake: And then maybe it's like April 10th and 18th.
Jake: 然后倒完就花掉
Jake: And then once it's done, just spend it.
Jake: 就这种嗯行吧
Jake: Something like that, alright.
Jake: 对直接站上去换
Jake: Yeah, just stand up and replace it.
其他人：导到导到哪
Others: Replace it where?
Jake: 导到这几台电脑中的一就是找到
Jake: To one of these computers, just find one.
Jake: 导到一个硬盘上面
Jake: Transfer it to a hard drive.
Jake: 就在我房间的一个硬盘上面
Jake: On a hard drive in my room.
Jake: 我们现在先换
Jake: Let's replace it first.
Jake: 哇这东西真的是你妈苦力
Jake: Wow, this thing is seriously hard work.
其他人：确实是
Others: It really is.
其他人：是不是没想到这个数据导出来要这么麻烦
Others: Didn't expect transferring this data to be so troublesome, huh?
Jake: 我靠这这go Pro这么菜
Jake: Damn, this GoPro is so weak.
Jake: 我靠不是我们之前算过
Jake: Damn, didn't we calculate it before?
其他人：只有这个
Others: Only this one.
Jake: 我们之前算过
Jake: We calculated it before.
Jake: 这个go Pro他story里应该没这么多
Jake: This GoPro shouldn't have that much in its story.
Jake: 但是他嗯我也不知道
Jake: But it, um, I don't know either.
Jake: 所以前几天的第三视角数据不
Jake: So the third-person data from the past few days...
Jake: 就不知道能不能用
Jake: We don't know if it's usable.
Jake: 但是我们希望从今天开始能用
Jake: But we hope we can use it starting today.
Jake: 呃往里面摁
Jake: Uh, push it in.
Jake: 哎不不不另一边
Jake: No, no, no, the other side.
Jake: 另一边
Jake: The other side.
其他人：这个吗
Others: This one?
Jake: 电池的那一边
Jake: The side with the battery.
Jake: 对就这个卡这个卡
Jake: Yeah, this card, this card.
其他人：这个就这个卡
Others: This one, this card?
Jake: 摁出来摁出来
Jake: Press it out, press it out.
Jake: 摁一下能弹出来对吧
Jake: Press it and it should pop out, right?
其他人：对然后这个在哪读呢
Others: Yeah, then where do we read it?
Jake: 不是先放进去先换掉
Jake: No, put it in first and then replace it.
Jake: 成功了吗
Jake: Did it work?
Jake: 那刘帅上去指导一下
Jake: Choiszt, go and guide them.
其他人： 哎这个卡是
Others: Hey, this card is...
其他人：这个大的是干什么
Others: What's this big one for?
Jake: 这大的就是读卡器哦嗯
Jake: This big one is the card reader, oh.
其他人：哦
Others: Oh.
其他人：我来吧
Others: I'll do it.
其他人：然后刚才我摘的十五号
Others: And just now I took out the fifteenth.
其他人： 要先先写十五号
Other: We need to write down the fifteenth first.
其他人： 然后对我先把这个搁进去
Other: And then, I'll put this in first.
Jake: OK
Jake: 呃等会等会等会这是什么不
Jake: Uh, wait, wait, wait. What's this?
其他人：这是15号
Other: This is the fifteenth.
Jake: 哎坐
Jake: Hey, sit down.
Jake: 我们顺着拿啊
Jake: Let's take it in order.
Jake: 不要按顺
Jake: Don't skip the order.
Jake: 哎你下的有点快
Jake: Hey, you're going a bit fast.
Jake: 因为你还要装一个上去
Jake: Because you need to put another one on.
Jake: 要把一个卡装
Jake: You need to put another card on.
Jake: 你装装完了是吧
Jake: Did you finish putting it on?
Jake: 哦OK行行对对对没问题
Jake: Oh, OK. Alright, alright, no problem.
其他人：现在这是刚刚那个旧卡
Other: Now this is the old card.
其他人：对对对
Other: Yeah, yeah.
Jake: OK
Jake: 呃来走一遍流程啊
Jake: Uh, let's go through the process.
Jake: 就是这个是十五号
Jake: So this is the fifteenth.
Jake: 然后你刚刚拿过来了对吧
Jake: And you just brought it over, right?
其他人：哎这个是新卡是吧
Other: Hey, this is the new card, right?
其他人： 这个新卡
Other: This new card.
Jake: 对啊对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Jake: 10号11
Jake: Number 10, 11.
其他人： 这怎么装呢
Other: How do we install this?
其他人：这怎么装
其他人：刚刚是我发烧了
Other: I had a fever earlier.
其他人：就直接这么塞就行啊
Other: Just push it in like this, right?
其他人： 哎你应该能直接卡住
Other: Hey, it should lock in place.
其他人：这个不用对上
Other: No need to align it.
Jake: 我靠你怎么
Jake: Damn, how did you...
Jake: 哈哈怎么回事你们都
Jake: Haha, what's going on with you all?
其他人：这个我装进去
Other: I put this in.
Jake: 没没有摄影过
Jake: No, no filming.
其他人： 嗯
Other: Mm-hmm.
Jake: 这个是15
Jake: This is the fifteenth.
其他人：15
Other: Fifteenth.
Jake: 好然后给你一个
Jake: Alright, and then I'll give you one.
Jake: 九十十给你12
Jake: Nine, ten, eleven, I'll give you twelve.
其他人： 这个我怎么看他装完了以后好像啊
Other: How come it looks like this after he installed it?
Jake: 回头我来看
Jake: I'll check it later.
Jake: 你先装对九十111212
Jake: You first install the ninety 111212.
Jake: 给你一个13
Jake: Here's a 13 for you.
Katrina: 在在这吃吗
Katrina: Are we eating here?
Jake: 哎我好可以行
Jake: Oh, yes, it's fine.
Katrina: 楼下没位置
Katrina: There's no space downstairs.
Jake: 好在这吃吧
Jake: Okay, let's eat here then.
Jake: 我收一下
Jake: I'll clean up a bit.
其他人：这个相机我碰了一下有问题吗
Others: Is there a problem if I touched this camera?
Jake: 没问题你肯定要碰
Jake: No problem, you're supposed to touch it.
其他人：这是13
Others: This is the 13.
Jake: 咱咱
Jake: We, we...
Jake: 咱这么多人够做的下不
Jake: Can so many of us fit?
Jake: 哎呦不不不不不
Jake: Oh no, no, no, no.
Jake: 我靠
Jake: Damn.
其他人：刚刚卡我放这
Others: I just put the card here.
Jake: 哦这个不是哦
Jake: Oh, this isn't it.
Jake: 哈哈哈人类早期新闻
Jake: Haha, early human news.
Jake: 我靠装装不进去
Jake: Damn, it won't fit.
Jake: 打打不开我靠
Jake: I can't open it, damn.
Katrina: 123456
其他人：还要搞个14
Others: We need to make another 14.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
其他人：我写吧贴盒上
Others: I'll write it and stick it on the box.
其他人：哪个14和15
Others: Which one is 14 and 15?
其他人：还有几个那就多一张卡是吗
Others: How many more, so there'll be an extra card?
其他人：多一张卡
Others: An extra card.
Jake: 9 10 11 12 13 14
Jake: 9 10 11 12 13 14.
其他人：15
Others: 15.
其他人：14这个然后
Others: This is 14 and then...
Jake: 啊我买了15张
Jake: Ah, I bought 15 cards.
Jake: 给我16张真的吗
Jake: Gave me 16, really?
Jake:1234567
Jake: 1234567.
Jake: 就7个是吧
Jake: Just 7, right?
其他人：对
Others: Yes.
其他人：确实多个一个是吗
Others: There really is an extra one?
Jake: 没有没有没有
Jake: No, no, no.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
其他人：一楼那个也得换一楼
Others: The one on the first floor also needs to be replaced.
Jake: 回头换一楼
Jake: We'll replace the first floor later.
Jake: 现在还有点空间
Jake: There's still some space now.
Jake: 因为第一天是在这录的
Jake: Because we recorded here on the first day.
Jake: 对对
Jake: Right, right.
Jake: 然后回头你们各领一个电脑开始传
Jake: Then later, each of you take a computer and start uploading.
Jake: 领一台电脑传
Jake: Take one computer and upload.
Jake:啥呀
Jake: What?
Jake: ntu
Jake: 什么意思
Jake: What does it mean?
Jake: approved
Jake: approve是什么意思
Jake: What does approve mean?
Jake: 为什么不说accept
Jake: Why not say accept?
Jake: 为什么说approve
Jake: Why say approve?
其他人：那这事错了
Others: That's wrong.
其他人：我靠确认三四遍
Others: Damn, confirmed three or four times.
Jake: 哎this is Singapore
Jake: Hey, this is Singapore.
其他人： 对确认三四遍
Others: Yeah, confirmed three or four times.
其他人： 这个叫什么
Others: What is this called?
其他人：这个surface software game
Others: This surface software game.
Jake: 对你你你
Jake: Right, you, you, you.
Jake: 问问谢宾如
Jake: Ask Xie Binru.
Jake: 新加坡是什么样的行政体系
Jake: What's Singapore's administrative system like?
Jake: 牛逼
Jake: Awesome.
Jake: 很严谨很严谨很严谨很严谨很严谨
Jake: Very meticulous, very meticulous, very meticulous, very meticulous, very meticulous.
Jake: 哈喽哎
Jake: Hello, hey.
Alice:录完了
Alice: Finished recording.
Jake: 录完了关了是吧
Jake: Finished recording, turned off, right?
Lucia: 关了
Lucia: Turned off.
Jake: 哦好
Jake: Oh, good.
Lucia: 但其实我主要是在玩白板
Lucia: But actually, I was mostly playing with the whiteboard.
Lucia:  因为我没画我懒得晚上卸妆
Lucia: Because I didn’t put on makeup, I'm too lazy to remove it at night.
Jake: 导师给我画的脸我我怎么卸妆啊
Jake: The instructor did my makeup, how do I remove it?
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 你
Tasha: You.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈好好好
Jake: Hahaha, okay, okay, okay.
Lucia: 可以借我们的卸妆油
Lucia: You can borrow our makeup remover.
Tasha:  加入土门免费获得
Tasha: Join the club and get it for free.
Tasha: 免费画免费卸
Tasha: Free makeup and free removal.
Tasha:  怎么还不心动
Tasha: How can you not be tempted?
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake: 因为没钱 256
Jake: Because I have no money. 256.
Tasha: 好习惯了
Tasha: Fine, I'm used to it.
Tasha: 天降特惠
Tasha: Sudden special offer.
Shure:  没给我们三点
Shure: Didn't give us three points.
Jake: 有有有放心
Jake: Yes, yes, yes, don't worry.
Jake: 你放心
Jake: Don't worry.
Shure: 差点以为我们被抛弃了
Shure: I almost thought we were abandoned.
Shure: 差点以为你们被当牲口
Shure: I almost thought you were treated like livestock.
Jake: 食材食材哈哈哈
Jake: Ingredients, ingredients, hahaha.
Lucia: 食材哈哈哈
Lucia: Ingredients, hahaha.
Jake: 哈从从传销组织已经变味了
Jake: Haha, the pyramid scheme has changed.
Lucia:  男女通吃的小哥哥一枚啊
Lucia: A guy who appeals to both men and women, huh?
Shure: 好好
Shure: Okay, okay.
其他人：哎刚刚那些卡那些卡收起来了
Others: Hey, those cards, those cards, put them away.
其他人：这个是干什么的
Others: What's this for?
Jake: 这个是充GoPro的电
Jake: This is for charging the GoPro.
Jake: 唉这些go Pro
Jake: Sigh, these GoPros...
其他人：可以
Others: Got it.
Jake: 对唉
Jake: Yeah, sigh.
其他人：插排还是不太够用
Others: The power strip is still not enough.
Jake: 不是我买了他三天就是在快递三天
Jake: No, I bought it three days ago, it's been in the mail for three days.
Jake: 然后每次都取不出来
Jake: And every time I can't get it.
Jake: 因为他要不就是什么一个人
Jake: Because it's either just one person...
Jake: 不知道在哪
Jake: I don't know where.
Jake: 还有什么
Jake: Or something else.
Jake: 反正就没给我
Jake: Anyway, they didn't give it to me.
Jake: 我靠好烦
Jake: Damn, so annoying.
Katrina: 零几啊
Katrina: What number?
Alice:03
Alice: 03.
Alice:可以单独买吗
Alice: Can you buy it separately?
Alice:这是双头吗
Alice: Is this a dual-head?
其他人：这个绿的就是充好的是吗
Others: This green one means it's fully charged, right?
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Yes, yes, yes.
其他人：这连个提示都没有
Others: There's no indicator at all.
Jake: 是不是对这个
Jake: Is it for this one?
Jake: 这个你摁一摁就有
Jake: You press it and it'll show.
Jake: 呵呵
Jake: Hehe.
其他人：那接触不好
Others: It's not making good contact.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
其他人：那能充上吗
Others: Can it charge?
Jake: 我不理解
Jake: I don't understand.
Jake: 反正它绿了
Jake: Anyway, it's green.
其他人： 那能充上吗
Others: Can it be charged?
Jake: 我不知道啊
Jake: I don't know.
Jake: 它绿了对
Jake: It's green, right?
Jake: 他好歹是绿的
Jake: At least it's green.
Jake: 哎换上卡之后瞬间富裕了起来
Jake: Oh, after swapping the card, I instantly became rich.
Jake: 我感觉
Jake: I feel...
其他人： 确实
Others: Indeed.
Jake: 可以开始录了
Jake: We can start recording now.
Shure: 军火多了
Shure: Got more ammo.
Jake: 军火多了对
Jake: More ammo, right.
Shure: 你们下午是要学yes ok是吗
Shure: Are you guys learning "yes ok" this afternoon?
Jake: 什么你们
Jake: What do you mean "you guys"?
Jake: 是你们哈哈哈
Jake: It's you guys, haha.
Katrina: 我怎么让你站c位了
Katrina: Why did I let you stand in the center?
Tasha: 你是c位
Tasha: You're the center.
Alice: 我是边角位
Alice: I'm on the edge.
Tasha: 哇你是中位
Tasha: Wow, you're in the middle.
Alice:你还可以
Alice: You're still okay.
Jake: 那个跳过是吗
Jake: Are we skipping that part?
Lucia:  vocal vocal
Lucia: Vocal, vocal.
Tasha: 呃你边唱边跳
Tasha: Uh, you sing and dance.
Tasha: 你确实因为你唱歌不是挺好听的
Tasha: Really, because your singing is quite nice.
Shure: 没有
Shure: No.
Alice:男团出道
Alice: Debut in a boy band.
Tasha:  女团出道啊哈哈
Tasha: Debut in a girl group, haha.
Jake: 你俩跳吗
Jake: Are you two dancing?
Jake: 哈哈哈不理我吃
Jake: Haha, ignoring me, just eating.
Shure: 我洗个爪
Shure: I'll go wash my hands.
Jake: 哎开始打富裕仗
Jake: Oh, starting to fight rich wars.
其他人：哎这个报错了怎么弄
Others: Oh, this error, how to fix it?
Jake: 有点开心
Jake: A bit happy.
Jake: 突然富裕了起来
Jake: Suddenly became rich.
Jake: 不是还得还是得拖来两人
Jake: But still, we need to drag two more people.
Jake: 让我以下开心的多了
Jake: Makes me much happier.
其他人：他这个不知道
Others: He doesn't know.
其他人：昨天晚上我已经打好车了
Others: Last night, I already booked the car.
Jake: 啊啊
Jake: Ah, ah.
Jake: 因为昨天也没到货
Jake: Because it didn't arrive yesterday.
Jake: 所以用这个确实报错
Jake: So using this does give an error.
Jake: 我得问问看怎么办
Jake: I need to ask what to do.
Shure: 坐坐坐大家不要不好意思
Shure: Everyone, take a seat, don't be shy.
Jake: 这个停
Jake: Stop that.
Shure: 开吃开吃我要饿死了
Shure: Let's eat, let's eat, I'm starving.
Jake: 好
Jake: Alright.
Jake: 很难不好意思
Jake: It's really hard, sorry.
Tasha: 这碗补够
Tasha: This bowl isn't enough.
Shure: 没事分批吃
Shure: No worries, we'll eat in shifts.
Tasha: 分批吃
Tasha: Eat in shifts.
Katrina: 还有零食我先吃
Katrina: There are snacks too, I'll start with those.
Shure: 然后你们再吃
Shure: Then you guys can eat after.
Tasha: 那后批的人吃的
Tasha: Then the people eating last...
Tasha:  全都是残羹冷饭
Tasha: ...will only get leftovers.
Alice:洗洗手吧
Alice: Let's wash our hands.
Lucia: 或者就把那个也拉过来
Lucia: Or we can bring that over too.
Jake: 洗完了哈哈
Jake: Washed already, haha.
Lucia: 对那这个也不够
Lucia: Yeah, this isn't enough either.
Jake: 拿上来几个呗
Jake: Bring a few more.
Jake: 拿上来几个呀
Jake: Bring a few more, yeah.
Jake: 12345678再来两个是吧
Jake: 12345678, bring two more, right?
其他人：这个要给他搬出来搬
Others: We need to move this out.
其他人： 稍微搬出来
Others: Move it out a bit.
Lucia: 这上面有一个电插板的线
Lucia: There's a power strip cable up here.
Jake: 没地放是吧
Jake: No place to put it, right?
Jake: 拔了吧不
Jake: Unplug it, no?
Shure: 怎么还不够13人这样就可以最后的晚餐
Shure: How come it's not enough for 13 people, this could be the last supper.
Jake: 是你拔了
Jake: Did you unplug it?
Jake: 拔了你拔了
Jake: Unplug it, you unplug it.
Jake: 他能落地上吗
Jake: Can it fall to the ground?
其他人：它要不能落地上
Others: It can't fall to the ground.
Jake: 那那你别你别
Jake: Then no, don't, don't.
Shure: 开饭开饭
Shure: Let's eat, let's eat.
Jake:再来几个椅子吗
Jake: Do we need more chairs?
Tasha: yes 123456 6个
Tasha: Yes, 123456, 6 chairs.
Alice:还差两个
Alice: We still need two more.
Jake: 好好好
Jake: Okay, okay.
Tasha: 也不知道杨老板坐哪里
Tasha: We don't know where Jake will sit.
Shure: 杨老板哈哈
Shure: Jake, haha.
Jake: 那坐不是那个
Jake: Where to sit, isn't that...
Jake: 要不戴一会
Jake: How about wearing it for a while.
Katrina: 我吗
Katrina: Me?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Katrina: ok
Katrina: Okay.
Katrina: 应该有电吧
Katrina: It should have power, right?
Jake: 有电有电
Jake: Yes, it has power.
Jake: 那我这个先放下去
Jake: Let me put this down first.
Jake: 哈哈什么东西
Jake: Haha, what is this?
其他人：你再重新出去一遍
Others: Go out and come back in again.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Huh?
Shure: 我们给你放BGM你在进
Shure: We'll play some BGM for you to come back in.
Jake: 好行
Jake: Okay, sure.
Jake: 搬个椅子上来
Jake: Bring a chair up.
Jake: 我不是我不是
Jake: It's not me, it's not me.
Jake: 在厂里头看的呀
Jake: I saw it in the factory.
Jake: 气质是不是不太对
Jake: Does the vibe seem off?
Tasha: 有一位吃完了
Tasha: Someone finished eating.
Shure: 这怎么还没到那个呢
Shure: Why haven't we reached that part yet?
Lucia: 要不再走一遍
Lucia: How about doing it again?
Lucia: 重拍一条
Lucia: Let's reshoot it.
Jake: 重拍
Jake: Reshoot.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake: 好下午一定
Jake: Okay, definitely in the afternoon.
Jake: 这个都开了
Jake: It's all turned on.
Jake: 哎
Jake: Hey.
Jake: 有饭吗嗯好谢谢
Jake: Is there food? Okay, thanks.
其他人：筷子还有
Others: There are still chopsticks.
Alice: 要不用勺
Alice: Or use a spoon.
Lucia:  嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Alice:我今天拆出了一根隐藏款
Alice: I found a rare piece today.
Jake: 好谢谢
Jake: Okay, thanks.
Katrina:  哈哈哈 3只筷子他那个
Katrina: Hahaha, three chopsticks, that one.
Jake: 这怎么吃
Jake: How do I eat this?
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Lucia: 打开补充装
Lucia: Open the refill pack.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Jake: 三脚架
Jake: Tripod.
Katrina:  要开空调吗好热
Katrina: Should we turn on the AC? It's so hot.
Katrina:  找找我那个
Katrina: Look for mine.
Tasha: 空调遥控器在我房间里
Tasha: The AC remote is in my room.
Jake: 哈什么
Jake: What?
Katrina:  我房间也有空调
Katrina: I have an air conditioner in my room too.
其他人：遥控器
Others: The remote.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
其他人：那你拿一下
Others: Then get it.
Tasha: 他挡住我的门了
Tasha: He's blocking my door.
Katrina:  我来
Katrina: I'm coming.
Tasha: 哦你也有
Tasha: Oh, you have one too.
Shure: 咦惨不忍睹
Shure: Oh, it's a mess.
其他人：看人家的私人房间
Others: Look at other people's private rooms.
Jake: 你戴眼镜了吗
Jake: Are you wearing glasses?
Shure: 没戴
Shure: No.
Jake: 对但是他OK
Jake: Yeah, but he's okay.
其他人：你这个眼镜很有迷惑性
Others: Your glasses are really confusing.
Katrina:  这能通用吗
Katrina: Can this be used universally?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Katrina:  应该可以吧
Katrina: It should be fine, right?
Jake: 可以可以
Jake: Yes, yes.
Shure: 哦一会把我那屋空调关一下
Shure: Oh, can someone turn off the air conditioner in my room later?
Shure: 我一直没有遥控器
Shure: I never had a remote.
Alice:那天我跟杨老板借遥控器
Alice: That day I borrowed the remote from Jake.
Jake: 你说
Jake: Go ahead.
Alice:然后我想试一下这个遥控器能不能用
Alice: Then I wanted to test if this remote could work.
Alice: 就把他房间开开
Alice: So I turned on his room.
Shure: 然后突然把我房间到现在才一直是开
Shure: And then suddenly my room has been on ever since.
Shure: 然后他一会吹冷风一会吹热风
Shure: And it keeps switching between cold and hot air.
Jake: 所以所以是什么模式啊
Jake: So, what mode is it on?
Shure: 不知道是什么模式
Shure: I don't know what mode it is.
Shure: 他太奇怪了好吧
Shure: It's too strange, okay?
Shure:  然后
Shure: And then...
Shure:  我那屋就陷入一个特别尴尬的东西
Shure: My room fell into a very awkward situation.
Shure: 又不冷又不热的一个
Shure: Neither cold nor hot.
Tasha: 不冷不热特别好嘛
Tasha: Not cold nor hot is perfect, right?
Katrina:  这不是很适宜吗宜居啊
Katrina: Isn't that comfortable? Livable.
Shure: 就是
Shure: Exactly.
Shure: 盖被还嫌热
Shure: Too hot with a blanket.
Shure: 不盖被还嫌热
Shure: Too hot without a blanket.
Jake: 谢谢
Jake: Thanks.
Jake: 这这什么菜啊
Jake: What is this dish?
Tasha: 烤番茄
Tasha: Baked tomatoes.
Jake: 土豆吗嗯
Jake: Potatoes, right?
Tasha: 年糕鸡
Tasha: Rice cake chicken.
Jake:年糕鸡
Jake: Rice cake chicken.
Katrina:  味道还不错
Katrina: It tastes pretty good.
Katrina:  就是它分量有点少
Katrina: But the portion is a bit small.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Katrina:  我应该再多点两层
Katrina: I should have ordered two more layers.
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
其他人：这个
Others: This one.
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
Katrina:  开空调了
Katrina: Turn on the air conditioner.
其他人： 我以为是糖醋
Others: I thought it was sweet and sour.
Lucia: 我以为是被塑料的东西
Lucia: I thought it was made of plastic.
Tasha: 没尝出他的东西
Tasha: I couldn't taste his stuff.
Lucia: 包括这个也很奇怪
Lucia: Including this one, it's also very strange.
Lucia: 就是他又有点像辣白菜味
Lucia: It's kinda like spicy kimchi.
Lucia: 又有点像水煮什么的味啊
Lucia: But it also tastes like boiled something.
Tasha: 什么什么泡菜
Tasha: What kind of kimchi?
Tasha:  不知道从从上往下点
Tasha: I don't know, let's order from top to bottom.
Katrina:  知道从从上往下点了一遍哈哈哈
Katrina: Yeah, let's order from top to bottom, haha.
Tasha: 不知道这两个菜我都没有尝过
Tasha: I haven't tried these two dishes.
Tasha: 我只经常吃这两个菜
Tasha: I only eat these two dishes often.
其他人：这就是那个人
Others: That's the person.
其他人：人气榜前面
Others: The top of the popularity list.
Tasha: 呃就是我经常爱吃的两个菜
Tasha: Uh, these are the two dishes I love to eat.
Jake: 这是什么
Jake: What is this?
Jake: 哪家呀韩国
Jake: Which place in Korea?
Tasha: 因为这是土门吧
Tasha: Because this is Tumen, right?
Katrina:  这是土门
Katrina: This is Tumen.
其他人：米村拌饭
Others: Rice Village Bibimbap.
Jake: 这叫米村
Jake: It's called Rice Village.
Alice:是朝鲜朝鲜非遗
Alice: It's North Korea's intangible cultural heritage.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
其他人：查一查还没吃过这个
Others: Check it out, haven't tried this one.
Jake: 朝鲜米村
Jake: North Korea's Rice Village.
Jake: 朝鲜有是是这意思吗
Jake: Does North Korea have a place like this?
Jake: 朝鲜有一个地方叫米村
Jake: Is there a place in North Korea called Rice Village?
其他人： 米村可能是个人
Others: Rice Village might be a person.
其他人：米村就是姓米的他家的村
Others: Rice Village could be a village owned by someone with the surname Mi (Rice).
Jake: 哈
Jake: Ha.
其他人：还真是那个朝鲜料理
Others: It really is that Korean dish.
Jake: 人
Jake: People.
Tasha: 我都说了是朝鲜料理
Tasha: I told you it's Korean food.
其他人：不是不是看错了
Others: No, no, you saw it wrong.
Jake: 日本人这个名字听起来
Jake: This Japanese name sounds...
Jake: 这个大麻茶哪来的呀
Jake: Where did this hemp tea come from?
Tasha: 大麻茶哈哈
Tasha: Hemp tea, haha.
其他人：冰箱里冰箱里
Others: From the fridge, the fridge.
其他人： 你喝可乐啊
Others: You drink cola.
Jake: 昨天买的是吗
Jake: Was it bought yesterday?
Jake: 对嗯
Jake: Yeah, it was.
Shure: 人家大妈馋
Shure: The lady is craving.
Shure: 就是领导要啥你给
Shure: Just give the boss whatever they want.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈你
Jake: Hahaha, you...
Shure: 怎么在北京活下来的
Shure: How did you survive in Beijing?
Jake: 哈哈哈还
Jake: Hahaha, still...
Tasha: 还好老板不是北京人
Tasha: Good thing the boss isn't from Beijing.
Shure: 你快去山东进修两年
Shure: You should go to Shandong for two years.
Tasha: 做事滴水不漏
Tasha: Be flawless in your work.
Jake: 这个能录吗
Jake: Can this be recorded?
Shure:  哈哈哈这教AI做人哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha, teaching AI to be human, haha.
Shure: 咱不能这么说
Shure: We shouldn't say that.
Shure:  应该叫AI做机
Shure: We should call it making AI work.
Jake: 哈哈哈这情况
Jake: Hahaha, this situation...
Katrina:  更奇怪了
Katrina: It's even stranger.
Shure: 想什么呢
Shure: What are you thinking?
Shure:  这写成文本一点毛病没有
Shure: There's no problem if this is written down.
Shure:  想歪了是你心脏
Shure: If you think otherwise, it's your heart.
Shure:  干什么
Shure: What are you doing?
Lucia: 你在扫描周围环境吗
Lucia: Are you scanning the surroundings?
Jake: 没有我在看灯有没有亮
Jake: No, I'm checking if the lights are on.
Jake: 下午整啥来着
Jake: What are we doing this afternoon?
Jake: 下午
Jake: This afternoon...
其他人：他们是要跳舞吗
Others: Are they going to dance?
Jake: 跳舞对这娘们
Jake: Dance? Yeah, those women...
其他人：我吗
Others: Me?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yes.
Jake: 你要跳吗
Jake: Are you going to dance?
Tasha: 你教我编剧都
Tasha: You teach me scriptwriting...
Jake: 那可以跳
Jake: Then you can dance.
Tasha: 编剧也都要跳的
Tasha: The scriptwriters also have to jump.
Tasha: 可以跳我们刚刚说好了
Tasha: They can jump, we just agreed.
Jake: 嗯好
Jake: Hmm, okay.
Jake: 那可以跳
Jake: Then they can jump.
Tasha: 你跳吗
Tasha: Are you going to jump?
Jake: 跳他肯定跳
Jake: He'll definitely jump.
其他人： 他肯定跳
Others: He'll definitely jump.
Shure: 我可以不跳
Shure: Can I not jump?
Tasha: 那我们七个人了
Tasha: Then there are seven of us.
Tasha: 哈哈七仙女
Tasha: Haha, seven fairies.
其他人：谁不跳
Others: Who's not jumping?
Shure: 我不跳了
Shure: I'm not jumping.
其他人： 他不跳
Others: He's not jumping.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
其他人：选好了那个
Others: The selection is done.
Katrina: 该咱选了吗
Katrina: Is it our turn to choose?
Katrina: 啊OK
Katrina: Ah, okay.
Jake: 跳过吗
Jake: Are we skipping this?
其他人：没有
Others: No.
Jake: 跳过吗
Jake: Are we skipping this?
Tasha: 啊这个你跳肯定很
Tasha: Ah, if you jump, it will definitely...
Katrina:  放五十二
Katrina: Put fifty-two.
Tasha: 适合你
Tasha: Suit you.
Jake: 紫藤最近什么时候来啊
Jake: When is Violet coming lately?
Jake: 不知道啊
Jake: I don't know.
Katrina:  哈哈没事他带头
Katrina: Haha, it's okay, he's leading.
Tasha: 我以为那个是放大声音
Tasha: I thought that was for increasing the volume.
Katrina:  让这个叫什么
Katrina: Let Shure lead.
Katrina:  修硕带头
Katrina: Shure can lead.
Jake: 修硕亮相是吧哈哈哈
Jake: Shure is making an appearance, right? Hahaha.
其他人：正好七个人
Others: Exactly seven people.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yeah.
其他人：草正好七个人
Others: Exactly seven people.
其他人：没有我是吧
Others: No, I'm not included, right?
Jake: 有你有你
Jake: You are, you are.
其他人：奥草加上我7个
Others: Oh, including me, it's seven.
其他人：哈哈嗯草
Others: Haha, yeah.
Katrina:  哈哈哈3个男生4个女生
Katrina: Hahaha, three guys and four girls.
Jake: 处到位处到位是吧处到位
Jake: In position, in position, right? In position.
Jake: 没进
Jake: Not in.
其他人：要不要
Others: Do you want to?
其他人： 练一下直接去
Others: Practice a bit and go straight?
其他人：什么练动直接去
Others: What, practice a move and go straight?
Tasha: 哦是练习生
Tasha: Oh, it's a trainee.
Jake: 练习生练习生啊
Jake: A trainee, a trainee.
Jake: 你这头发还挺好的
Jake: Your hair looks pretty good.
其他人：没事
Others: No problem.
Tasha: 我天那
Tasha: Oh my gosh.
Jake: 这头发值得solo一下
Jake: This hair deserves a solo.
其他人：没问题
Others: No problem.
Katrina:  都是起舞吧
Katrina: Everyone, start dancing.
Jake: 就是独舞独舞一下
Jake: Just a solo dance.
Tasha: 噢噢噢噢噢
Tasha: Oh oh oh.
Lucia:  可以给他松露插入一个松露段落吧
Lucia: We could insert a truffle section for him.
Tasha:  要不啊
Tasha: How about...
Tasha:  就是那种拍那种转场
Tasha: Like those transition shots.
Tasha:  然后一个人出来跳
Tasha: And then someone comes out to dance.
Lucia: 对对对就比如说大家知道队形
Lucia: Yes, yes, for example, everyone knows the formation.
Lucia: 跳完之后向两边散开
Lucia: After the dance, they spread out.
Lucia: 然后一个人出来跳
Lucia: And then someone comes out to dance.
Tasha: 然后在这这样子
Tasha: And then like this.
Tasha: 然后他就一个人开始跳好对
Tasha: And then he starts dancing alone, right.
其他人：靠这么夸张
Others: Wow, that's so dramatic.
Lucia: 一些高光段落
Lucia: Some highlight sections.
Katrina:  穿裙子不
Katrina: Wearing a skirt?
Katrina:  哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
其他人： 哈哈没问题
Others: Haha, no problem.
Katrina:  没问题
Katrina: No problem.
其他人： 我的腿不跟你开玩笑
Others: My legs aren't joking with you.
Jake: 哈哈哈是的是的
Jake: Hahaha, yes, yes.
Katrina:  很可爱是的是的哈哈哈
Katrina: So cute, yes, yes, hahaha.
Shure: 可以扒吗
Shure: Can I strip?
其他人：没问题
Others: No problem.
其他人：踢足球的时候每个男的都难摸我的腿
Others: When playing football, every guy has trouble touching my legs.
Jake: 为什么
Jake: Why?
其他人：因为太诱人
Others: Because it's too tempting.
Shure:  他长得像
Shure: He looks like...
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahahaha.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈哈哈哈可以的
Katrina: Hahahahahaha, it's fine.
Tasha: 这个是可以录的吗
Tasha: Can we record this?
Katrina:  国外更那个
Katrina: It's more like that abroad.
Shure: 都他妈是姐妹
Shure: They're all damn sisters.
Katrina:  也统一服装吗感觉他们那个
Katrina: Do they also have uniform outfits? It feels like they...
Jake: 统一什么服装
Jake: Uniform outfits for what?
Jake: 就这个服装
Jake: This outfit?
Katrina:  裙子
Katrina: Skirts.
Jake: 裙子
Jake: Skirts.
Jake: 可以那愿意拨款
Jake: Sure, if you're willing to allocate funds.
Katrina:  我找找教程哈哈
Katrina: I'll look for some tutorials, haha.
Katrina:  我哈哈什么
Katrina: Haha, what was that?
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake: 统一服装愿意拨款
Jake: Uniform outfits, willing to allocate funds.
Katrina:  okay现在开始看
Katrina: Okay, let's start now.
Lucia: 老板大气
Lucia: The boss is so generous.
Tasha: 要不我来挑衣服吧
Tasha: Why don't I pick the outfits?
Lucia: 可以啊可以啊
Lucia: Sure, sure.
Shure:  真的统一服装啊
Shure: Are we really going to have uniform outfits?
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Tasha:  哈哈哈老板都说脱谎了
Tasha: Haha, the boss is really committed.
Shure: 我靠
Shure: Damn.
Katrina:  拨款呢
Katrina: Allocating funds?
其他人： 我操统一服装他妈还得把腿毛刮了
Others: Damn, with uniform outfits, we even have to shave our legs.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina:  哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Lucia: 你看人家已经开始认真考试了这是
Lucia: Look, they're already taking the exam seriously.
Katrina:  这这这个很有爱豆的觉悟
Katrina: This really shows their idol mindset.
Shure: 穿个厚一点的丝袜解决
Shure: Just wear thicker stockings to solve it.
Tasha: 要不大家穿裤子
Tasha: Why don't we all wear pants?
Tasha: 一定要穿裙子是吧
Tasha: Do we really have to wear skirts?
Shure: 你也要这腿不漏白瞎
Shure: You need to, or else those legs will go to waste.
Lucia: 那我觉得我们邀请别人来的时候
Lucia: I think when we invite others over,
Lucia: 就有一个很大的卖点耶
Lucia: it will be a major selling point.
Katrina: 卖点哈哈
Katrina: Selling point, haha.
Shure: 我们这
Shure: Our...
Katrina:  慢一点
Katrina: Slow down.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
其他人：那我补参加了
Others: Then I'll participate.
Jake: 你做个pose做个海报
Jake: Strike a pose for the poster.
Tasha: 诱骗失败了
Tasha: The trick failed.
其他人：我以为就今天跳了得了
Others: I thought we were just skipping today.
其他人： 没想到今天只是排练
Others: Didn't expect today was just a rehearsal.
Lucia: 嗯对今天只是排练
Lucia: Yeah, today is just a rehearsal.
Katrina:  刚刚敲定还没学
Katrina: Just finalized, haven't learned it yet.
Jake: 对星期天
Jake: Yes, on Sunday.
Jake: 星期天再跳
Jake: We'll dance again on Sunday.
其他人：那我可以当导演
Others: Then I can be the director.
Tasha:  哈哈他要换个位置
Tasha: Haha, he wants to change positions.
其他人：跳不了一点
Others: Can't dance a bit.
Jake: 好好
Jake: Alright, alright.
Tasha: 好啊嗯那我也要到
Tasha: Okay, well, I'll also join.
Lucia: 好稳定的情绪哈哈哈
Lucia: Such stable emotions, hahaha.
Katrina:  我这哈哈
Katrina: I'm like, haha.
Katrina:  是不是跟他说什么好
Katrina: Should we tell him something good?
Jake: 这梳子要扔吗
Jake: Should we throw this comb away?
Lucia: 啊这这个是放垃圾的吗
Lucia: Ah, is this for trash?
其他人：不不不是
Others: No, no, it's not.
Alice:这是微微的梳子
Alice: This is Tasha's comb.
Lucia: 我看这里面有很多我感觉是
Lucia: I see a lot in here, I feel like it is.
Jake: 哦哦这个是素菜是吧
Jake: Oh, oh, this is vegetarian, right?
Jake: 哈哈啊
Jake: Haha, ah.
Jake: 这是什么
Jake: What is this?
Lucia: 什么素菜
Lucia: What vegetarian?
Jake: 不知道
Jake: I don't know.
Jake: 水母素菜
Jake: Jellyfish vegetarian.
其他人：出去一趟你能出吗
Others: Can you go out for a bit?
Tasha:  我这不能出
Tasha: I can't go out.
Tasha:  如果你愿意嫁给我
Tasha: If you want to marry me.
其他人： 啊不说了一会再说吧吃完再说
Others: Ah, let's talk later after eating.
Katrina:  从这下面走
Katrina: Go down this way.
其他人：你说这条路
Others: You mean this way?
Tasha:  没有没有
Tasha: No, no.
Tasha:  好我也出我也出
Tasha: Alright, I'll go out too.
其他人：谢谢
Others: Thank you.
其他人：这个壶也是你们买的
Others: Did you guys buy this kettle too?
Alice:不是吧
Alice: I don't think so.
Lucia: 他带的吧
Lucia: He brought it, right?
Katrina:  看咱还有啥
Katrina: Let's see what else we have.
Katrina:  我靠这包子扔了吧
Katrina: Damn, should we throw these buns away?
Katrina:  乐的
Katrina: So funny.
Jake: 包子好
Jake: The buns are good.
Katrina:  扔了吧
Katrina: Throw it away.
Alice:那个人带的
Alice: That person brought it.
Katrina:  哎我们没有交换礼物的环节
Katrina: Hey, we don't have a gift exchange segment.
Jake: 有呃
Jake: We do, uh...
Jake: 晚上吧某个晚上吧某个晚上
Jake: Tonight, maybe some night, maybe tonight.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Jake: 就今晚吧就今晚吧
Jake: Let's do it tonight, let's do it tonight.
Katrina:  都行我只是提醒他有一个环节
Katrina: Fine, I was just reminding him there's a segment.
Jake: 好的好的好的
Jake: Okay, okay, okay.
Jake: 交换礼物
Jake: Gift exchange.
Katrina:  让我们自己带吗
Katrina: Are we supposed to bring our own?
Jake: 礼物
Jake: Gifts.
Katrina:  让我们自己带礼物吗
Katrina: Are we supposed to bring our own gifts?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Lucia:  哈哈不行
Lucia: Haha, no way.
Lucia:  懒得卸妆
Lucia: Too lazy to remove my makeup.
Tasha: 现在
Tasha: Now?
Alice:不然你等会
Alice: Or wait a bit.
Tasha: 都可以
Tasha: Either way is fine.
Shure: 手充这个能
Shure: This can be charged by hand.
其他人：那个加热
Others: That one heats up.
Shure: 不是这是秤
Shure: No, this is a scale.
Jake: 哎这要充电
Jake: Oh, this needs charging.
Jake: 是吗
Jake: Right?
其他人：啊
Others: Ah.
Jake: 这要充电
Jake: This needs charging.
其他人：给它充满再充
Others: Charge it fully first.
Jake: 嗯行
Jake: Hmm, okay.
其他人：这个配比就是
Others: The ratio is...
Katrina:  衣服洗完了晒衣服
Katrina: Clothes are washed, time to hang them.
Jake: 哎你这些操作能录就录好吧
Jake: Hey, if you can record these steps, go ahead.
Jake: 不是不是不是就是
Jake: No, no, no, I mean...
Jake: 你你你可以下午再搞好
Jake: You, you, you can do it in the afternoon.
Shure:  嗯那我现在戴个眼镜吧
Shure: Hmm, I'll put on my glasses now.
其他人： 您先给我搞一个
Others: You do one for me first.
其他人：然后下午再搞
Others: Then do the rest in the afternoon.
Jake: 哦那也行
Jake: Oh, that's fine too.
Jake: 刘帅帮我把那个卡楼下的卡都换了
Jake: Choiszt, help me replace the cards downstairs.
其他人：就是gopro的
Others: The GoPro ones?
Jake: 对跟谢斌竹都换了
Jake: Yes, replace them all with Xie Binzhu's cards.
其他人：你要做我就等你做完了再换
Others: If you want to do it, I'll wait until you finish and then switch.
Jake: 也行
Jake: That works too.
Shure: 先换吧我先带个隐形眼镜
Shure: Let's switch first, I'll put on my contact lens.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
其他人：那个卡是不是哦在这呢
Others: Is that card... oh, here it is.
其他人：怎么一股糊味
Others: Why does it smell burnt?
Jake: 这要丢掉这
Jake: This needs to be thrown away.
Tasha: 下午干嘛
Tasha: What are we doing this afternoon?
Alice:打麻将
Alice: Playing mahjong.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Alice:能凑够四个人吗
Alice: Can we get four people?
Tasha: 这么多人凑不够四个
Tasha: With so many people, we can't get four?
Jake: 4个活动
Jake: Four activities.
Alice:杨老板不是要干嘛
Alice: Isn't Jake supposed to do something?
Jake: 没有啊够够的
Jake: No, we have enough people.
Jake: 这3个
Jake: These three.
Tasha: 下午几点钟开始
Tasha: What time are we starting this afternoon?
Alice: 数据倒出来了吗
Alice: Have the data been transferred?
Jake: 正在倒
Jake: It's being transferred.
Jake: 2点半吧
Jake: Around 2:30.
Alice:2点半
Alice: 2:30.
其他人：你在这吗
Others: Will you be here?
Jake:可以啊
Jake: Sure.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 嗯真棒
Jake: Hmm, great.
Tasha: 够买睡个午觉
Tasha: Enough time for a nap.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Tasha: 是吗口红
Tasha: Really? Lipstick.
Jake: 嚯
Jake: Whoa.
Tasha: 怎么了
Tasha: What's up?
Jake: 美
Jake: Beautiful.
其他人：那这个我们该怎么做
Others: So how should we do this?
Shure: 就是直接兑奶或兑水
Shure: Just mix it with milk or water.
其他人：哦
Others: Oh.
其他人：你会拉那个花吗
Others: Can you make that design?
Shure: 能拉但是它是不是花不一定
Shure: I can make it, but whether it looks like a flower is another story.
Shure: 它可能是屎
Shure: It might look like poop.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
其他人： 我只能说说
Others: I can only say...
其他人：修硕拉花水平我是认可的
Others: I acknowledge Shure's design skills.
其他人：是吗
Others: Really?
其他人：人家都是拉花
Others: Everyone does latte art.
其他人： 都是那个咖啡机的问题
Others: It's all the coffee machine's fault.
其他人：不是修硕的问题
Others: It's not Shure's fault.
Shure: 我回家拉那些是不是都能
Shure: If I go home and try, can I still do it?
其他人：咖啡机还能拉花
Others: The coffee machine can still do latte art.
其他人： 我回家我后来自己去拉也还行
Others: When I went home and tried it myself, it was fine.
Shure: 真的是那个咖啡机
Shure: It's really that coffee machine.
其他人：你那这玩意简直是一坨
Others: Yours is just a piece of...
其他人：我操
Others: Damn.
Shure: 才300块钱
Shure: Only cost 300 bucks.
其他人： 咖啡店店里都是大几千的
Others: Coffee shops have machines that cost thousands.
Shure: 后来我我这套手冲还500多块钱
Shure: Later, I got a pour-over setup that cost more than 500.
其他人：哎呀我操
Others: Oh my god.
Shure: 您悠着点
Shure: Take it easy.
Jake: 太幸福了
Jake: So happy.
Jake: 别摔摔了算工伤
Jake: Don't fall, that'll count as a work injury.
Jake: 赔不起哈哈哈
Jake: I can't afford to pay for that, haha.
其他人： 买个保险哈
Others: Get some insurance, haha.
Jake: 可以
Jake: Sure.
Jake: 五五十 50块钱保险
Jake: A 50-dollar insurance.
其他人：包含北京
Others: Covers Beijing.
其他人：北京地区救援
Others: Rescue in Beijing area.
其他人：最近有一个新闻
Others: There was a news story recently.
其他人：那个人
Others: That guy...
Shure: 买的保险
Shure: Bought insurance.
其他人：不包含尼泊尔
Others: Didn't cover Nepal.
其他人：他他妈爬珠穆朗玛峰爬到尼泊尔去
Others: He climbed Mount Everest and crossed into Nepal.
其他人：在尼泊尔死了
Others: Died in Nepal.
其他人：然后救不了
Others: Couldn't be rescued.
Shure:  呵呵呵他过国界的
Shure: Haha, he crossed the border.
其他人：他妈太厉害了
Others: Damn, that's impressive.
Jake: 就特地写的不要尼泊尔是吧对
Jake: They specifically wrote "not covering Nepal," right?
其他人：对
Others: Yeah.
Jake: 眼镜我来
Jake: I'll handle the glasses.
Jake: 呃就现在可以停了吧
Jake: Uh, should we stop now?
Shure: 把我的眼镜给你传出去是吧
Shure: You're going to share my glasses, right?
Jake: 传了对
Jake: Yeah, shared.
Shure: 嗯我的
Shure: Uh-huh, my...
Shure: 我的珍贵影像
Shure: My precious footage.
Shure: 就昨天晚上
Shure: Just last night
Shure:  记得单独发给我吧谢谢
Shure: Remember to send it to me separately, thanks.
其他人：这么块你应该一直先弄
Others: You should have been working on it all along.
Jake: 我靠那快递什么时候给我拿呀
Jake: Damn, when will the delivery get to me?
Jake: 靠
Jake: Damn.
Jake: 烦
Jake: Annoying.
Shure: 我把那个音箱给装上
Shure: I'll install that speaker.
其他人：看电影活动
Others: Movie watching event.
Jake: 啊是什么活动
Jake: Huh, what event?
其他人：我不知道刚刚那个修硕说的
Others: I don't know, Shure just mentioned it.
Jake: 啊没有这个活动
Jake: Huh, there's no such event.
Jake: 这个坐着不行
Jake: This sitting arrangement won't work.
其他人：还有这种好事
Others: There's such a nice thing?
Jake: 演电影可以
Jake: Acting a movie is fine.
Jake: 不看电影不行
Jake: Not watching a movie won't work.
其他人：啊这是4
Others: Huh, this is 4.
Shure:  （歌词）一起拉拉芬芳
Shure: (lyrics) Together we'll pull the fragrant
Shure: （歌词）骑上最快的马
Shure: (lyrics) Ride the fastest horse